i just want to tell you about tonight
what's going to happen because i'm
hosting i know everyone's doing
something different every night i
contacted my friend john mcdonald he
owns this really great restaurant it's
on the ocean beach whatever and he has
great music it's called the conch shack
actually luanne and i were there like
like four five six years ago aha i'll
never forget don't tell them
this is the one that you [ __ ] block
everybody
what do you think
she went in and said i don't give a [ __ ]
about these girls i might marry this guy
and live on this island no i don't know
i was into him i was flirting i was into
him oh okay wait a minute what happened
that was when i decided i couldn't be
with my ex-husband anymore it was over
you were married at the time yeah so you
were flirting with you no he's getting
divorced he's cheating me for a year
just said you were flirting with him one
minute ago yeah because i was getting
divorced [ __ ] wait what
excuse me because you don't understand
anything i say why are you calling me a
baby because you don't listen to me
that's not acceptable what you're not
going to do on this trip is call me a
[ __ ]
i don't know how
you are in new york but [ __ ] you're not
going to just don't step on this donut
anywhere
okay i don't even like being caught a
[ __ ] on a normal day but from a near
perfect stranger
[ __ ] please
this is insane guys i can't be fighting
for a room it's beneath me fine she can
have it is this fixed
let's just do that i don't know i'm not
gonna fight with people okay i don't
care all right we have beautiful homes
enough
this will be our suite me and kyle we're
gonna share this as a big suite what
she's not getting is she cannot do all
the things she's done and then feel like
she gets the best room ramona
ramona
party
romana she's in the shower ramana can we
talk to you for a minute
it's naked she's in the shower i haven't
known this lady a day and now i've
already
seen her naked give us some privacy
really
oh my god we just got here and we got
seven more days to go good morning honey
don't let ramona scare you out of tennis
i don't know i want to play tennis with
you good morning what are you wearing
nothing oh
you want to see it
oh my god
like jesus christmas can i get some
coffee first michael was so sorry to be
inappropriate i just saw your little
puss that's so cute
and i haven't seen hair in such a long
time do you take any creamers
i do but i'm going to get a spoon in a
larger cup okay
[Music]
are you kidding me
is that dangerous only if you bother
them can someone look out for the
stingray let me single it
you
i've got ramona on the boat a stingray
in the water i mean
oh no i just see snapped i'll take the
stingray esther williams watch out oh my
god
i definitely need to learn how to serve
i'm going to help you out
so lou's the master of volleyball for
sure so we'll wait for her to come down
unless you want to pre-teach me a serve
sure so that i don't get embarrassed in
front of everybody whoa that rock yeah
there you go i am playing the damsel in
distress but actually i don't know how
to serve i need someone to teach me hit
it out of your hand nice and low bend
your knees a little bit and then just
and then come up exactly right yep
that's all right that was good let's
face it he has a rock hard body he's a
beautiful smile and i want to learn some
pointers i'm going to start with our
hostess kyle
the kind of key to your chart is that in
your past lives
you were
more often than not a man
[Music]
i've heard that a man
yeah i've been a man of my past lives
yes and now you can see so yeah
men deal with emotions differently than
women you were general in a past life
that's what i was told oh my god i was
already told i was a general in the past
well i'm picking up the same past life
so it must be true i was literally told
that
i'm the only man of the group
who knew i'm the only guy here
well whatever you'll love this past life
you were a queen darling
but you married a commoner
marrying down
there was no dentist in the room there
was no toilet bowl scrubbers in the room
cynthia you were married to a very
powerful man you're also a visionary
i've heard that before where's all my
plumbers at melissa yeah your past life
you were a beautiful princess of a small
country we're all royalty i don't know i
like the princess part
this one's for luanne this is for you
yeah but i'm gonna make it easy for you
okay i'm gonna put it in my mouth yes
and then i'm gonna sit up and you have
to try and get it from my
[Applause]
mouth all right michael if you insist
okay
here we go
[Music]
that's how you do it that's how you do
it because you got a little baby mouth
there you go
[Music]
[Laughter]
you got a ramona come on you got guys
[Music]
oh
do you think you are ramona you don't
talk to me like that you called me a
[ __ ] the first time that we met yeah
now you're trying to come to me on my
boat do you want your ass thrown over
the wall all right throw me over baby
what's wrong with you you're a snazzle
you
[Music]
theresa did she insult you yes she did
cynthia did she insult you
[Music]
let me get back to you okay how did she
insult you keep it moving
because what you're not going to do is
disrespect me
you're putting your fingers i'm pointing
my fingers at you yeah
[Music]
i wanted to keep it very basic so i'm
like when the person in front of you
goes this way you go that way
one by one what are you joining can you
go the opposite yeah there you go no
opposite okay yeah
this way to the right to the left to the
left to the right to the left
ready go hit the red button
[Music]
everybody was going the same way hands
were going up guards were reaching out
oh lord no wait cynthia just looks like
somebody's grandmother right now
i didn't even realize we were doing a
tick tock
you go this way
i go this way
go this way
try one more one more when is it going
to stop
come on guys
[Music]
the wrong person was in front had
melissa been in front of me i would have
killed
i was thrown off and
thrown out i'm going
all right so what's the point of this
do i want to roll across the water
no problem
can i get a blow out while i'm in here
maybe you're going to get a blow out
already
look look at her it's your beyonce
moment yes bring it oh my god
this is so weird
oh yes
she knows how to work a ball you know
what i mean ladies
yes
now hamster it for me hamstring that's
sexy show me gerbil show me gerbil oh
oh hold her oh she's doing it wait no oh
that's good luanne i didn't say i was
gonna do it wait wait
i have a mic
the hell would i just step up
i do love a good roll in the hay so why
not a hamster wheel
yes yes
oh my god
wow
looking for anything because i'm happy
with that but i mean i love i love it
would you like to intelligent
intelligence
you know beauty fades but you know so
luanne
is very intelligent
and uh
obviously she's very funny yeah so do
you have a physical type
oh poor johnny gonna put him on the spot
he's alright
well let's see
let's do this does he like blondes or
brunettes
yeah i feel bad for ramona cause i know
she likes john but see this is the thing
you can't keep poking the bear because
when you poke the bear
you never know how the bear's going to
react ramona went for kenya a lot of
times called her [ __ ] and you know [ __ ]
you and
and now kenya's like [ __ ] you i spent
some time with you guys and you know a
couple and i was expecting a little more
drama and you guys all seem to like each
other and it's really refreshing and
nice no i mean it's nice i mean you're
like i'm ramona you weren't paying
attention
don't get interested
at the beginning of the trip you should
have seen what happened on the yacht the
other day
what happened on the yacht the other day
do we have the repeat strategy cause
you're all on such a good pace oh my god
we were taught we we just had a crime we
had a crazy brother we didn't really
talk about it right now they were
talking about
uh ramona tried to blackmail
actually no
it's almost like when you're at like
dinner with your children and you're
grinding your teeth and you're like you
better behave ramona was like girls
we're gonna behave nicely we're at my
friend's house and then kenny's like
yeah no we're actually not i got cursed
dead and then you know
she told me to click off
and then there was crying and running
around and it was like oh my god okay
well she was
looking like she was crying but there
were actually no tears coming out of her
eyes
wow
[Music]
[Music]
she a caribbean
you